best thing once you're through testing
testing
I
we're
hey how's it going gonna see her oh no
good just just need a run of few lines
of code and put in one more graph G
major fine yeah I shotgun oh thank you
thank you yeah I was like I was like
[ __ ] i'm presenting I can't be a shaggy
like fur ball when I'm talking for
everyone got a fat guy look good but uh
did I'm ready for more distant oh yeah
okay yeah beard too little little little
patches if I can't go slow speech
anything yeah yeah I'm in some pizza
ready for some more more porn whole time
it's time you have a freakin stud
awesome good luck
well
here
or
you
like
Oh 1 2 3 testing 123 I hope the internet
can hear me loud and clear okay I owe
all my codes up there or not I'm not
supposed to see that let's see
hey professor Lowell thank you for
coming i really appreciate your call my
son a nice to meet you well this is
great everyone's here now I can't say
anything wrong without without losing
something because of it um yeah I wanted
to introduce you to two Jared and my
boss are kind of busy but we also have
the guy who does the race cars like from
a car here as well let me see if I can
find them for you real quick yeah
Jarrod's busy he's a statista back here
this is the people from Mekhi I don't
know if you know Josh she's a PhD
student at he was a triple e hey Josh
have you met professor law course of
course a while he and there's a
department of course of course in
Mohamed is our one of our advisors for
the team shoes the chief engineer last
year and he's going to be one of the
teats yeah I don't I can't find my
bosses from work but the real estate
company i'm doing a lot of our for them
and like data analysis of all their
building so I've been kind of like using
everything it's been super fun but of
course help yourself to some pizza I
think there's parent there's beer in the
fridge water am I gonna do it okay
awesome
aha
yes
that worked better than I thought
jo three
is there an audio for this there could
be all the initiative is their audio the
hdmi doesn't do all your ears man cuz I
know it's it's required but it's a fight
it's fine to do it um we could hook it
up the audio and I think I'll be fine
with my computer over the video well I
just want to play this whole people were
coming in I wanna so you know it's
cooler with the audio but they can kind
of see that the car still really fast oh
sorry I no worries
okay i have like another like two or
three minutes until the video goes up
one quick thing
you
Oh
ha
look at jitter whenever you're ready I'm
ready
we can
Oh
Charles Jason this is my boss MOOC and
my other boss Frank
Oh
they just make fun of me like y'all do
it's nothing like a different okay we
should be getting started
I hope you all enjoy the presentation I
should be starting whenever whenever
Jared's ready oh my god what I this is
what I build a race car in the shirt
built a race car
ok
and
okay we're in this time
Oh
Marie
all right all right all right whoo it
seems like a lot of newcomers does it
would do sure Wow so do are you here for
armed or research this little bitter
coffee right who doesn't know why do I
don't cry for a race cars versus one
will get to our speaker in a little bit
who's going to be turned off my own
thing apparently someone sat down in
front of the camera oh yeah that was my
mom texting me haha okay
hey so those who are you you will be
starting off the meetup the very
important question who is hiring for the
job announcement with a cool one anyone
hiring so I reason start working at IBM
we're hiring were about five blocks up
I am
any of the job if you're interested in
jobs go to the pH on our message board
whether Josie is one Rocco right now so
very good place to buy yourself a job
you are slowly nothing else all right
that's that second of all those who
don't cover me with big boobs or someone
open source derek allen equals 0 let's
go oh just something I take a cake Oh
we'll talk later next day those who are
new here we go everyone into the pizza
everyone has people Dakota last 12
people who ate a very same so everyone
today please take your smartphone's
enjoy right loan or Windows Phone or
blackberry that happens don't have hurt
beyond a pleasure I'm old and it's going
to fix so everyone who's here he's too
busy / pizza bullets they badly slashed
piece of the bowl and give us ratings
pizza
good average score ever again it's a
pizza italia we love 17 Street area so
please go ahead and make the pizza after
this Robin Hood the bar that's where the
real game begins that right house at 73
between businesses are too bright house
after the matter the talk next up taking
ebay ebay post this for a while to use
with amazing space it's really awesome /
water perspectives so we're in love
taylor hall from ebay
oh yeah well pull the el tren speaker we
are biased remember
roughly anyone twenty cent discount I
don't really like you GE New York's I'm
mushroom code go to the other page it
was anything else of days and message
board the twenty cent discount code for
grab some pretty awful there is also
next month hadley winco teaching the
two-day masters course our development
one day of sr one day a package
development I know that today in the
email blast and it's on the message
board but after a contact me two hundred
ologist happen yeah the discount code
right now like 0 8 17 16 feet up I'm
asking them to change that I won't leave
all that out to the group the Twins have
just time to ever happy with them
September 1213 also happy but young
advil meet up sometime over 13 so it
varies so should be very excited about
this heather with them is demigoddess to
unity I highly never come down but are
securely we're going to a hard stop in
towards your 50 people laughter bespoke
we add
38 whimpers wait so sign up at only go
tomorrow sometime in october november
there will be a carry class by next to
ya kerry when your buddy nice to me to
masculinize don't care which lets you
will automatically routine dream house
he'll be giving a class of one of the
two day class metra class sometime in
November pending optically the gorgon
city say about that he's really awesome
these actually pretty good kickboxer we
loaded the conference those who nervous
doesn't matter to too much but we are
live streaming this on two different
services we're trying to see which one
actually works well so people who are
getting streaming tell if you don't
periscope or you to fly over the
available the tweet try and please let
us know which ones work this way we know
what to do go in covert and people
sitting here the cameras you mind your
maybe say could bear will be picked up
on the camera actually packet will be
picked up
maybe not you to fly just keep them
acceleration all right then I'd like to
do giveaways right oversight of two ways
all right we've pushed up yet t-shirt
revolution we have little boats that
your bowl all things from O'Reilly and
we have a few books so if there's one at
a time I'm gonna read off the names you
can our speaker handle humble Sammy's
out where to first up the phone wallets
oh you win wage well congrats all right
Christopher Forgione hey come on down or
nice all right that was no no I can
throw yeah I know him perfect can you
hold this upper bay we have a revolution
blogger now there's a backstory funky
fella
and we've been drinking a lot and we
started with Aurra Bob's we ended up
with the monkeys and the guy that I work
with that's the dumbest idea I've ever
seen in my life I won't put it on it not
anything they're stupid so we googled
flying straight a month and as a result
of that they became our mascot the first
conference we had those at we gave away
eight thousand at jsf and they're flying
all over the point where they could does
that letter is low so this is thank you
curtis clark of monkey inspired by a
drunken tiger it the winner of this is
sourcing Schmidt nice new t-shirt cannon
Congrats all right next up not as I say
and I are not as well we also have I
Arnie or t-shirts so those are a box of
my apartments they're not here this is
my David Smith the guys big in the our
community about blogging about our to in
order to win you need to provide proof
your first and last name folks so next
up is yours way here it all right you
get a ir New York no and I hard our
teacher
if you guys want the eye on your t-shirt
or the NYC day the mountain t-shirt
email me I'll make sure to hear next
week okay next up we have a book by have
the wake up yeah the winner of that is
Dave proper hey he just that's wonderful
and our next prize is another point
might have the width up in fact the same
boat this will go to he's not here so
Stephens all away you never either man
all right Dan sokil off so the grand
prize of a second how the women book all
right Mike Lawrence that use that you
you want it nice and lastly sweet and
authentic piece of June
we'll go to the founder of evolution
some are really hard with everything
what this was I'm not repeating what you
said runner Billy flat beautiful how to
the next month Stroud and Hadley
discounts right house after the talk and
less chance alright I give you our
speaker Matthew thank you thank you 10
sweet that work correctly okay hi
everyone um this is making race cars go
faster with our or also known as when
Jared asked you to make a presentation
you have to redo your final project so
I'm going to do that I have two guests
here that I've been helping out the team
one is Josh Brown right here looking
down his phone he's a former NASCAR
engineer so he'll be able to call any
[ __ ] on any of the race car
terminology and then we have professor
am on your wall who is a master of like
statistics and you know applied to
basically discovered some machine
learning stuff I think so yeah a big
deal so let's get right into this quick
few things i'm going to probably spend
the first 5-10 minute she's talking
about vehicle dynamics i'm going to
spend another few minutes talking about
some of the methods I use and then I'm
going to go talk about what actually
came out of my results so scaling
properly so when I posted my paper for
my environmental data analysis class to
the formula sae forum the guy who's
actually head of the calspan tire
Research Center was nice enough to email
me these new sexy photos of their
testing facility so what you see in the
middle is a tire on a really big machine
and you see a sort of sandpaper like
belts but between these two big big
wheels supported on an air bearing
what's going to happen is that the
machine is going to change the amount of
force that's on it change the pressure
while also measuring how much force the
tires experiencing laterally and
vertically it's also going to change the
angle in this case we're seeing camber
angle beam change and the whole machine
is going to turn simulating the tire as
if you're driving the car in it you know
you're going into a turn so let's see if
this works there's actually no before we
get to go ahead a video here oh yeah
it's later okay so yeah that's tire
testing this is Formula SAE so this is a
student run club at Columbia University
it exists all around the world the
biggest competition America is Formula
SAE Michigan this is actually the
competition from Lincoln Nebraska oh we
build this car from scratch we do not
buy the engine we buy a CBR 600rr engine
we put it in a frame that weighs about
70 pounds we design our own suspension
components so we built our own a arms
caster own uprights machine our own
rockers we're in the CNC you know late
at night on weekends we were doing our
own welding we do our own carbon fiber
layups like this car is literally our
baby and it goes 0 to 60 in about four
seconds this is another cool picture of
the car you can sort of see it without
the wheels all the components you
designed we get the frame powder-coated
we have so we have some rules for the
competition so they require we build the
frame in a certain manner so that it
protects the driver in different parts
and we have limits on how big our engine
can be and we're not allowed to have
like professionals designer stuff we
have to do it we have to do it on our
own though we can have consulting like
people like Josh Brown helping us out
sort of being like why are you doing
that that's dumb do this and we're like
okay so and we learn how to do a lot of
this on our own too we're going to start
to have a class where it teaches the
vehicle dynamics but a lot of this stuff
is really self-taught
see if this will play
oh sweet so this is much better with
audio but you can basically see a
passenger car tire just get demolished
by this machine like usually we're not
going to be testing with that much force
on it but you can get an idea you know
this is a normal tire you know with 40
psi just being compressed to a contact
patch about a foot a foot long so that
must be a couple thousand pounds on that
tire not more and what it's going to do
is the whole machine is going to start
turning so you can actually calculate
the grip it gets as it does a sweep so
it should be starting that now and then
this is how it normally does it sweet
that's probably a regular amount of
pressure on this so because this machine
can test so many settings it also gets
really expensive to do tire testing if
you need to test five different
pressures three different camera angles
a few different tires it multiplies
really quickly and you can't do
thousands of thousands of tests so even
though have this machine being used for
I don't know a few days you've day it's
going to be like 20,000 plus dollars so
fortunately the competition has this
thing called the tire test consortium
we're all the teams pull together their
money so we can have access to this
machine and they run the test at cost so
that were they're not actually making a
profit the main thing is we're not
allowed to share the data with people
that haven't paid in so my stuff is kind
of like de-identified you don't know
what tire i'm looking at and then once
we once we we have to kind of
acknowledge like calspan and then being
so nice so I think I've done that Oh
wonderful I guess that's who watches a
watch is race car videos okay wonderful
this is not scaling properly
give me one second and everything's like
super zoomed in its scaling it's on my
laptop screen okay that's better um so
let's talk about how to make a how to
make a race car fast we like to put a
lot of money into this we spend a lot of
time working on it oh we better know
some engineering concepts and some
general theory for why it happens so a
first big obvious thing put a big engine
your car produce a lot of power your car
goes very fast right second thing that's
popular downforce these wings on the
front and rear of the car are going to
be pushing down the tires and you can go
around to turn a lot faster really good
downforce I don't I like men in black
downforce gone wrong in this situation I
think a car pulled in front of it and
kind of messed up the arrow so the car
just blew up in the air so fun stuff um
you can reduce your drag so this is the
supersonic car SSC with two big jet
engines on it that was the first car to
go to break the sound barrier you can
continue to lower your drag this is a
solar car it is the noonas 5 made by I
think it's health University in the
Netherlands so they test this in a wind
tunnel and make the frontal
cross-sectional area and the air drag
coefficient as small as possible of
course they're not trying to meet a top
speed per se but they're trying to go as
fast as I can on his little power as
possible one problem that that drag
racer on my first picture have that
Usain Bolt did not is that he's not grip
limited so he does need to have some
sort of tennis shoes in order to start
his run but throughout it his main limit
is actually going to be the power in his
legs not the power in his engine this
car however is smoking its rear tires
that shows us that we're at a point to
where the friction between the tires and
the ground
is not nearly high enough to compensate
for the torque that's being produced by
that tire so in this case sliding is bad
likewise you can think of other auto
race is sort of like soccer you're
trying to have to you know to changing
directions a lot you're making a lot of
turns likewise this is someone who
clearly overshot their turn they may be
broke too late as they're trying to
steer their front tire starts sliding
and they just slide off they're not
they're not going to make around the
turn um likewise drifting is never going
to be very fast so the main takeaway
here you want your tires to be
experiencing static friction not sliding
friction the actual contact patch of
your tire is not moving relative to the
surface of the road and that is the
condition at which we analyze most of
our stuff this is the condition at which
we do all of our load calculations if
you want to figure out how much force is
going into any member of your car you
have to figure out the amount of grip
that's on your tires and that actually
limits or I guess makes the max value of
whatever forces are going to be going
into any component okay so this is the
formula sae course this is actually the
one in germany lots and lots of turns we
don't have enough time to get up to a
high top speed so you have to maximize
how fast we're going to be able to turn
this is a picture of a friction circle
so the way that you can imagine a tires
grip is that if you're using grip to
accelerate you can't use that grip to
turn likewise if you're trying to turn
really fast and you want to slam on the
brakes while you're doing it well that
force you need to slow down isn't going
to help you turn and you're probably
going to start sliding once once you get
over that limit and that's very
important if you're ever you know maybe
about to hit someone on a car and you
decide you want to slam the brakes an
turn you really you really got to pick
one break first then turn or get off the
gas and then turn the wheel that's
important whenever your tire is turning
the rubbers actually deforming at the
contact patch so the rim of the tires
facing one direction and the contact
patch is twisting and facing another
direction and then filing this last
picture it's kind of hard to see buddy
illustrated how the how the slip angles
are formed and how the path of the tire
is kind of different from where it's
pointed one way you can kind of
visualize it is if you got like a bunch
of feet you know walking and each one's
kind of slowly going to the right and
each successive foot is making the car
move a different direction so you just
sort of you know doot doot doot and
that's how you're how your your tire is
actually producing a side force and the
part that's producing your lateral force
is actually static relative to the to
the ground they're going very important
thing i want to emphasize slip angle so
the difference between where your tires
pointed or where your rims pointed and
where your tires like trying to roll
that is what we're going to be analyzing
and my data I didn't mention anything
about weight when I was talking about
how to make a car go fast and it is
indeed important but the first thing we
kind of want to establish is that the
amount of friction that we have
available is going to be a function of a
coefficient of friction and a normal
force on the top right so the more
weight we have on the tire the more
force that's available to make it go for
make it go backwards vice versa so when
you have a drag racer you throw all your
weight to the back because your front
wheels aren't even aren't even rolling
so you need all the available force that
you can on the back that being said your
amount of lateral acceleration is going
to be divided by the amount of mass you
need to move sideways right and usually
the amount of mass that's producing
weight going down is equal to the same
thing as the amount of mass you need to
move sideways so you know increasing
weight or decreasing weight is only
going to help you so much if your power
limited if you don't have enough if you
don't have a big enough engine for your
car then you need to reduce the weight
to do it but if your engine gets so big
that it doesn't uh you know it can
overcome that then really what you need
to improve is your coefficient of static
friction that's going to be your main
limiter and there's one more quick point
I was going to make the reason why down
force increases your grip is when you
have those big arrow kits on your
formula car you can actually increase
the amount of
normal force that's on your tire but the
amount of the amount of weight that you
have to move sideways stays the same so
you're getting you're getting basically
free force from your tire granted your
engine has to work a bit harder to make
up for it because drag acts backwards
but you're getting more weight going
down without any more weight going
sideways so you just go into a turn real
fast let the aerodynamics push it down
and then that can actually pull the car
to the side with the same way that it
let it way sideways quick explanation of
camber angles so we have we're looking
at the car from the front if the tires
are facing out relative to the center
line of the of the car that's going to
be positive camber that's generally bad
for grip we're looking at it top of the
tires are pointed in that's negative
camber one thing that I have to do in my
data analysis is our tire testing
machine isn't defined in terms of
positive camber negative to Cambridge
defined in terms of inclination angle so
instead of defining a relative to the
center of the car they just define it
left as one way you know right right is
another way right is negative and so
when the tire actually turns a certain
direction at one point it's actually in
positive camber and other points of
negative camber within the same part of
the turn for anyone who's actually going
to going to analyze this data so when
the tire testing machine does its sweep
you're going to produce a slip angle vs.
a coefficient of friction curve and your
coefficient of friction at this point is
kind of the same as your lateral your
sideways force because you're still
developing your peak sideways forces you
turn your tire generally in your street
cars and a car that you have it's going
to look like this small dotted line the
reason for that is you don't need as
much grip as a race car tire but what's
really nice is you have this big flat
area so where once you get right here if
you accidentally you know turn the wheel
a bit more you're not going to suddenly
lose all your grip you have a range you
know a little bit of cushion that very
top one that says hypothetical
hypothetical tire that would be the
ideal for like a professional formula
one driver where it instantly gets up to
a lot of grip doesn't have much freedom
to stay there and so if you accidentally
turn your wheel too much you're actually
going to start sliding and that's going
to happen very fast and you're going to
fly off the course and we don't want
that so for our race car we want to kind
of we want to find a balance I want to
be searching for where the best grip is
but I also want to realize that we raise
our car the students are the drivers
we're not Michael Schumacher and we need
to be able to have a drivable car that's
easy to keep at the limit so why did I
do this project professor loll makes us
do a project for the environmental data
analysis class and the way that this
problem is generally tackled is to use
some proprietary software to fit the
data and I don't like it I don't
understand what's going on behind the
behind the in the black box and I prefer
to look at the raw data so this is just
sort of an example of something I pull
from our team where the purple line is
completely like vertically shifted
relative to the red line which makes
absolutely no sense and then when you
actually plot the raw data on the right
you see that they all kind of go through
the same center point so this is sort of
my inspiration and i was looking at this
so I'm like okay I bet you I can develop
my own statistics to to fit stuff to
this so i tried so this is some of the
raw data i believe this is at 10 psi
zero camber angle 150 pounds on the tire
doing a sweep and you can see the amount
of side force generated the first
tempting thing you do is this you print
it out you draw a pen you try to trace
and you're like ah ha my peaks there but
we can do we can do a lot better than
that and everyone that's try to attempt
this problem is if essentially trying to
make a curve that you know they know
what it looks like but it can't quite do
it because it's it's so noisy than they
want to they want to try to get a number
that exact so the very first main method
is called the magic formula so it's a
formula of the of the form you have this
constant sy which is a vertical shift
and at the very end you have sx which is
a horizontal shift of the curve you have
some sign art an atan curves and that
sort of gives you that little make sure
that gives you that will give you like a
nice rise and a part where it flattens
out and then
each of the coefficients BCD one will
affect your peak value one will affect
how high the curve continues before it
flattens out one will stretch it you
know so the person who made this is sort
of drawing his own curve with these
mathematical functions um this is simple
enough to understand but when you have
to make a multi-dimensional model though
the way that the tire professionals do
it is they call it a it's like a
dimensionless model so everything's /
some sort of variable so that you
actually don't have units of force units
of of pressuring units of everything
it's all kind of kind of normalize it
looks like that it's like five pages of
equations and I was just sort of I was
like screw that like I can't like it
there's no way I'm gonna sit down and
code all this stuff and use whatever
formula or whatever I'm like I hope that
there's some magic like equation in our
that can do this for me and the first
idea that came to my mind was k-nearest
neighbors and we'll get to that in a
second but you know let me let me try
plotting that to a simple you know
simple this that's over here okay
actually before we get there let's so
yeah I didn't want to do this so my
first inspiration was like okay let me
do a k-nearest neighbors regression so
for those of you who don't know what a
k-nearest neighbors regression is you
find your k-nearest neighbors so in this
case it's five in this case it's a
hundred points if you want to predict
what your value is for that point you
get the five nearest ones you calculate
the distance and then you bootstrap it
you sample those points like a thousand
times okay you calculate your
probability for each point based upon
the distance you draw a thousand of
those points and then you calculate the
mean of those of those thousand points
and hopefully by the time you do like a
thousand samples you should be getting
roughly the same point every time so I
could do a cane years neighbors
regression for any point on this plane
by just plopping a point here being like
ok these are the closest for this has a
distance of 11.5 1.7 1.8 give all those
a percentage based upon their distance
and then sample that okay and
for for this graph that would be the
equivalent of me saying okay I want to
guess what the value is right here let
me find the five closest ones and kind
of you know plop it in pop it in right
there which seemed like a good idea um
another method I wanted to try was local
regression so we're familiar with linear
regression where you try to fit a
least-squares line to a data but in this
case you actually pick an amount of
neighbors that you want to fit to your
model and then you find a certain amount
of closest ones and make them fit you
you you you fit a regression based upon
weights that are determined by these
kernels okay so in this case you know we
have a uniform kernel and so that might
say that if I want to fit a line 25 you
know to just five of those points I quay
them all equally but these other lines
that kind of curve down we'll say that
points that are farther away my
prediction will have less of an effect
on how it's a on how its fitted and then
finally there's this thing called a thin
plate smoothing spline and the way I've
sort of fit justified that in my head is
sort of like a 3d spline and so should
have had a picture of some some knots in
here but essentially I'm pretty sure a
lot of you all might have played with
CAD or even some stuff like MATLAB they
actually have spline packages in there
but you're sort of fitting a polynomial
to run through certain points inside of
a inside of a plane and then what this
does is it will do that in like as many
dimensions as you want try to minimize
the number of knots while also
minimizing the cross-validated residuals
and you can determine how smooth you
want it so you can actually run this
sort of surface through every single
point your data and get this really
noisy thing or you can pick a certain
amount to run it through and then get a
less noisy curve and much more smooth ok
so Jared's gonna be mad at me for using
base are for
for this part but essentially here you
actually see two lines there's the red
and the blue one it just me spitting a
one-dimensional spline the other ones me
using nonlinear least squares on the
magic formula so that big like art and
sine cosine stuff and it does this
really well for just one slice this is
one pressure one came brangle one tire
if I want to run this on every single
part of the data where I have three tire
pressures for camber angles a couple
different tires in different forces on
the tire it actually keeps breaking on
me it says like the step size that it's
trying to iterate to has gotten too
small and screw you mad I'm not going to
do this and I get really annoyed so I
gave up on that then I tried using a
generalized additive model and so in
this case I was trying to run a spline
on the slip angle part and then add the
amount of force on the tire and then
also add some sort of slip angle to the
power of n part and it this didn't work
this sort of you know it basically try
to make it a polynomial fit it over
these curves with the blue one being
Maya the raw data and the red being my
fit so that that didn't work oh yeah
sorry so it's all going to be this so if
I should it's not going to be
coefficient of friction or lateral force
and the coefficient of friction is just
a lateral force divided by the weight on
the tire so they're yeah they're both
going to show the same thing so that I
think the next you are all going to be
side force on the tire
okay so then I tried using Louis and
lock fit very badly just let me do a
little little plug for ggplot2 what I
absolutely love about ggplot2 is that I
could facet it by whatever variables i
wanted so on the side right here each
row is a different amount of force on
the tire so I go from 50 pounds to 250
pounds on the tire and then each of the
columns is a combination of camber angle
entire pressure and so this is 10 pounds
of pressure at negative 4 camber angle
10 pounds of pressure on negative 2 10
pounds of pressure at 0 positive 2 and I
can actually display every slice of my
data concisely on one thing for you know
engineer to see so that didn't work very
well the nice thing about a lock fit or
local regression is that you can
actually tune the amount of nearest
neighbors that it will consider in his
regression and so finally here I started
getting something that was actually
doable it was really following the line
I could display it across everything and
so I've just sort of having a guest like
where the peak is I could actually say
okay it's that part of the fit right
there and then this is when it wasn't
still working as well as smooth and
smoothing it out too much here here I
decided to flip everything into one
quadrant because of that came wrangle a
show us talking about so we're not to
worry about that and then eventually I
started getting some good graphs so this
is K nearest neighbors with ten nearest
neighbors on the curve you can kind of
see that for the higher loading so for
250 pounds one hundred fifty pounds it
produces a really nice smooth curve but
then as you do a hundred pounds 150
pounds it's following the noise of the
data too much local regression actually
looked pretty good the nice thing about
this I literally hit one command and it
ran this on everything and then these
almost look identical but the
generalized additive model I decided to
finally just run a spline just in that s
term I put all the variables inside the
spline term and let it run and it gave
me this fitted to that whole array of
values so here I finally compare
everything the black dots are the raw
data the red line is the magic formula
just ran on that slice of the data and
then the other ones are actually the
result for this slice when that
regression was run on the entire data
set and so you can kind of see like the
blue k-nearest neighbors is sort of like
jumping up and down and whatnot but they
all produce really nice smooth curves
there's some issue about them getting a
bit off like near the origin of the data
and that's because of the way i
transformed it but all in all they
produce really good fits and I wouldn't
mind using all of these it gets kind of
were so I tested the tire data to
different conditions condition a is I
believe 150 pounds with the normal
amount of pressure and then condition be
is just 50 pounds on the tire so because
the machines not putting too much force
there's actually more noise and the data
that generating you can kind of see the
variance increases as we go up and it
kind of wreaks havoc with the k-nearest
neighbors regression and they're all
sort of kind of looping up and down over
here over each other so I compared
everything and I was able to get the
Max's from it iterating the chamber in
steps of 0.1 from negative three degrees
camber to pause the three degrees camber
so the model Iran produced you know
something that could be fit at any point
I didn't have to just fit it at the
points where where the the data was
collected and so I ran this at every
every tenth of a degree and then told
you know at a single pressure and single
force and told me which one's the best
and it actually turned out that tire be
came ahead in terms of force at every
single time so if you see tire be here
is that
144 tire a is at 138 likewise tire bees
at 422 entire a is that you know 400
that actually represents a smaller
diameter tire we have these 10 inch rims
that we use in a 13 inch rims so what
was interesting here is you'd normally
expect the bigger tire to have more grip
but the smaller tire actually performed
a lot better and then the other thing
that was interesting to note is that
tire be tended to have higher slip
angles the entire a so because it's a
wider bigger tire the rubber doesn't
have to twist as much in order to
produce its maximum grip wears a smaller
tire had to twist more to do it that
means that the smaller tire is a bit
less responsive it's going to you know
as you turn the wheel is going to take a
bit longer to kind of set in its place
and give you the maxscript where is the
bigger tire while it produces less grip
will send its place a bit faster this is
a sort of an example of just running
that came running the the plots at every
single chamber you can kind of see from
from negative 3 to positive 3 the curve
is shifting just a tiny bit with each
step and that's useful so I can actually
find an optimum and then uh recently one
of my friends was like hey you know you
interpret a lay to the chamber why don't
you try and triple eight in the the
normal force and that messed everything
up it's not looking as good as bad right
here because it's still it's kind of
like turning into a polynomial in
between the the force on it but when I
ran this on like the kind of whole curve
before was transformed this was becoming
a straight line in between and I was
like gee how do I fix this and I was
trying to run different versions of the
model change the nearest neighbors and
all that didn't get anything until I
decided to scale the force data on it
and so you know added a line for
reference you can kind of see that as
your forces going down so is your
overall grip which is exactly what it
should do and then these rows without
the blue are just places where my model
is interpolating between two different
values so you can actually see here it's
at 50 pounds here it's at 75 oh
120 550 it's slowly getting larger and
larger and I didn't have to run any
twenty equation thing to do this this is
just like one command in our the thing I
had to do was change the force values i
divided them all by 50 so 250 became 5
you know a hundred became too and that
allowed the nearest neighbors part of
the algorithm to actually work better
because the scaling affects it if I'm
trying to find ten years neighbors and
my force goes between 0 and 2 50 but my
cambers between 0 & 3 it's going to
thank caber values and another test that
are actually closer because the total
range is smaller so once I scale it it
can actually use the values more fairly
Oh which I thought was was really
interesting and so usually in a
principal component analysis you're able
to scale everything to like a mean 0 and
a standard deviation of one if I use
these methods in the future might be
useful to scale my test variables to
that same range and then I'll be able to
run the regressions on them better so
and yeah and these were some final
graphs that kind of appeared kind of
going from both sides so you can see
when I'm interpolating the camber angles
really smooth it's gradually changing I
was able to run maxes and find optimal
values in between the camber angle
values so I was pretty excited about
that and uh that's everything so thank
you
sorry oh yes does anyone have any
questions what's up so like no could you
repeat the question oh yeah so what
you're asking if there's any obvious
values in the data that I could just
take out without even doing the doing
any analysis um I rounded some of the
values so I round a lot of the values to
the nearest like 50th 50 pounds and
that's just because there's noise and
the Machine kind of trying to push push
force on the tire but it didn't I didn't
have to throw anything out the thing
that one of the vehicle dynamicists
people recommended to me was only doing
one direction of turning the tire so you
can turn the direction left and turn the
direction right he's saying I should
probably focus on one of those because
the curve loops back on itself and it
adds funky things
so you of course so you ask a general
question why do passenger vehicles have
grooves in them and wire formula tires
no groups flat so though oh you wires
the compound okay I thought you're gonna
have grooves I guess that's a displaced
water yeah I think I think the lines
actually make it less weight so that you
can just uh oh there are these things
called like racing like rain slicks well
they'll just be one line in the middle
of it so I uses that to displace water
I'm not entirely sure
yeah so that's so your first question
was do things such as tire wear affect
the data it is true so the tire can wear
down the temperature changes as the
earlier runs or colder than the later
runs so all the times you have to
investigate more closely and be like do
I have this peak value at a place that
doesn't make sense because it's later in
the test run so in this case I actually
had some positive camber values that
were my peak and that might just because
the type B because the tires were warmer
that particular area so I do need to
regress it on more variables to get to
get a better model I did run it just
sort of on everything for that one
particular tire that one particular run
and then your second question was oh
right so you try different variables um
one thing I wanted to try was using the
same tire on different testing runs so
this is I use round six data so there's
been seven rounds of testing formula
tires um this round only had like two or
three kimber values that they tested
where's the other one tested five or six
and so what i could do is with the five
or six KIBRA values i create like a
training set in a validation set and
then use that to see how well the models
working I could all there's a lot more
variables in here and they also have
tests that aren't just going sideways
but are testing the acceleration
capacity of the tire I have not tried
running multiple tires within the same
model not even sure I know how to do
that but i'm pretty sure somebody could
i er
okay so your question was we get these
tires from a good entire data from a
testing facility because we could do our
own testing and somehow use that to kind
of like modify these results so if you
notice on this graph this y-axis varies
between negative 3 and 3 because it's
not showing the side force being
generated showing the coefficient of
friction in the real world you're not
going to have three times the amount of
side force as you do wait on the tire
for our car that number is going to be
more close to 1.5 so what you're seeing
here is there's a specific interaction
between our particular soft racing tire
and the material that their drum that
their belt is made out of that's
artificially increasing the coefficient
of friction to three and what's
interesting with racecars is that your
maximum acceleration that you can
experience is also equal to your
coefficient of friction so we have
accelerometers on our car we have a test
where we have a competition event where
we actually have to run our car in a
circle and try to do that as fast as
possible and that's the test our peak
side grip and so we could renormalize
these values with data based upon our
peak acceleration and conditions we know
about our car we might know that we have
a camber angle set a certain way we have
the tire pressure set a certain way we
have a particular type of asphalt the
Michigan competition isn't as sticky as
the Lincoln Nebraska competition because
the Nebraska competitions at an airport
they're sort of like infinity things to
do with this tire data and the joke is
that a racing tire has 250,000 degrees
of freedom like it's ridiculous oh
yeah I in terms of just run time for the
model i think the k-nearest neighbor oh
sorry his question was a there were some
models that you know I had to find
models that worked well and he was
asking if their difference and like you
know the time it took to train the
models in the time it took to run the
models so the k-nearest neighbors
actually has to calculate all the
distances between everything in fact I
use professor results code to do that
and so that's code that's an R it's
calculating like a bunch of different
distances so that one runs slower than
the other ones which are packages that
have been optimized I think in like seen
Fortran and stuff so the k-nearest
neighbor ones did take the longest i
think the thin plates moving splines
took the second longest especially
depending on how I how I set it up and I
think the local regression was the
fastest
so the heart the hard thing here is just
like you know even when I'm comparing it
to my magic formula it's like you know
which one's the best and so when I
managed to do oh yeah Jared was asking
which one had the best predictive power
I need to go and get some residual sum
cross-validated residuals for all this
but all the other models when I try to
interpolate between force values the
amount of force I was put on up on it
the k-nearest neighbors one just like
died it either stuck to the lower one or
stuck to the higher one I didn't do a
good job going in between and then the
local regression was even more smooth
than the the thin plate smoothing spline
so I think the one that has the most
potential is in the you know generalized
added a model package that then plates
moving splines okay awesome thank
thank you it was interested you'll be
going to write my audio coming check
your email so again thinking about thank
you oh thank you yeah he'll get his your
teeth Oh is your godavari should be more
for the one of course of course great
thanks for having me speak horse Hey
look program at Columbia are you oh I
just graduated from mechanical
engineering okay great let's go look at
the rusticity yeah yeah hey hey Cho well
thank you thank you appreciate it do the
actual town I was like I was like made
of us alone realize i remembered a few
things from his class I think okay an
honor system I evening ikea people don't
fail in here trying to broaden our you
can party nomination with a juco know i
was i started playing around
or might prevent a highway
okay type up my paper submitted John
good job cause I guess Ellen
I can put it on there
oh yeah I don't have it on get home but
I can put it up I guess I mean come on
if I email you some of this stuff have a
pen
thank you thanks
nice dog thanks for coming appreciate it
okay Frank thank you appreciate it sorry
I to listen and we talk about nerdy
stuff for an hour oh really Oh some
awesome things Thanks okay sweet so you
want me anymore interests in the
k-nearest neighbors feel nervous and
okay yeah and a lot of them are just
packages so the local regression is
called it's called lock fit loc midam
the I wanted to see the analysis part
not the arc or not seen okay so yeah I
have like a paper where I kind of went
through something so hey Josh thank you
so much I'll send it to you yeah okay
yeah yeah how's the paper posted a
formal forum but I should probably
shared somewhere else ok so you want
sorry so you want the analysis the
people oh yeah I can send you the paper
yeah um if you can remember that there's
a it's FSA com I'll write it down
and then forums and then there should be
one called like tire talk oh you know
what no it's sorry discussion and then
like tire okay okay so i posted in one
of the threads it's a really bad paper
but thank you yo dude thanks for coming
that was great good job thank you thank
you feel like so i finished the
presentation today and I was worried
they didn't have enough stuff in it but
then by some of us would we do i do the
talking like okay I'm good on time so no
you found it interesting yeah I didn't
get out of it I think I think I'll tag
expansion later like oh of course Howard
I think yeah because the hard thing too
is like the thin plates like some of the
stuff I don't understand a lot of tire
dynamics I tried my best to like slow it
down to where you could see how it was
relevant but then it just gets
theoretical really fast I've been in
that you're trying two sided which tire
works best yeah essentially and I had
some methods that we've drawn all those
regressions and stuff and then okay and
then to the last slide we prepared by a
retired be a point to make it out here
its tires or savings too or just like
yeah is that these methods can be
applied and just I don't have to fit
those 20 equations i had on the screen i
can just run my model that's a very
straightforward or code with different
data yeah plan a date using two years
before you two variables right oh no I
had like five variables actually okay it
was it was fitting like a like a
five-dimensional thing to it yeah I
guess I should have made that more clear
I think I think you did I was thinking
you're graphing oh yeah yeah that was
just too that was like a slice of it so
hey Jordan Georgia Tech it's good to see
you missed um I don't know did you get
to talk to josh brown or Sydney I think
we might have set out there are some
people from the Columbia team here other
people what's your name and Coburn Oh
Matthew you did you see it as you hear
about this on my forum posts or awesome
got some one person so yeah what are you
up to now make a new friend a little bit
if we go over the bar for level two oh
yeah also go to the bar have a beer or
two so let me talk to talk to noon we'll
come back oh thanks for coming Oh
Georgia Tech